selon nos sources la victime un homme de
28 ans d'origine sainte lucienne serait
en ce moment en soins en milieu
hospitalier pour le moment sérieusement
handicapé par rapport à cette balle qui
lui est transpercé les jours aucun
dialogue ne serait possible avec les
enquêteurs
les enquêteurs qui devront encore
patienter avant son audition
enfin peut-être de déterminer si
constant se précise de cette sauvage
agression une balle à bout portant
au niveau de la mâchoire un mode
opératoire qui laisse à penser à un
règlement de comptes
malgré de nombreuses recherches
effectuées hier sur ce site naturel du
clos maulier à saint joseph
les techniciens d'investigation
criminelle sont toujours à la recherche
d'un 10 et semblerait que l'auteur des
faits soit identifié mais que deux
autres complices souhaite aussi
activement recherché dans le cadre de
cette nouvelle agression par arme à feu
en martinique on l'heure les
investigations se poursuivent
l'enquêté confiée à la section de
recherches de la gendarmerie de fort de
france